good morning John it's Thursday January
25th yesterday you said it was Thursday
today I'm saying it's Thursday one of us
is wrong as you may have noticed in my
January 23rd video I'm currently in mom
and dad's little cabin on the side of
their house Katherine and I have begun
our yearly tour of the entire
southeastern United States we're
starting out Asheville North Carolina
which is right here then we're going to
jumped over to Athens Georgia to see
some friends and then jump back from
Georgia to Asheville and then we're
going to jump from Asheville to Orlando
that jump being in an airplane by all
accounts this is a lot of John ting and
then we're going to jump in a car from
Orlando to Tampa st. Petersburg to see
some friends and then from Tampa st.
Petersburg we're going to jump to
Inglewood Florida which is pretty far
down on the Gulf Coast
two of the three weeks I'll be on this
trip I'll be without high-speed Internet
not okay you said that you believe that
mom and dad's house was the last
residence in the United States of
America with dial-up internet you were
wrong there's an entire town on the Gulf
Coast of Florida without broadband
internet and I'm about to go there I'm
very concerned for what this means to
the Brotherhood 2.0 project I'm also
very concerned because a lot of people
have been coming up with a lot of very
good punishments these aren't the kind
of punishments that are just difficult
to do they're the kind of punishments
that are extremely embarrassing to have
on video blog and that's the kind of
punishments that we're going to want to
be doing so I've decided something as
the Brotherhood 2.0 brother who may very
likely be making his first foray into
punishment territory I would like to
suggest that the brother not being
punished decide which punishment to give
the brother being punished that way I
just don't take the punishment I'd most
want to do but you give me the
punishment you'd most want our viewers
to see me doing you will write about
another thing about Ash
Carolina's surrounded by memories of my
childhood you remember when Phil would
made us these little critter cages so we
could catch grasshoppers and store them
inside they can be punished for the
crimes of their incessant jabbing they
never really worked very well this
reminds me of my childhood because it is
a little dog that I made to resemble our
little dog red and a doghouse that we
never had doesn't actually fit inside
the doghouse
oddly enough one of the things that
reminded me most of my childhood in this
place is the food mom made shepherd's
pie last night also something I haven't
seen since I left home a craft American
cheese individually wrapped single it
smells like nothing I mean it doesn't
it's not cheese
doesn't look or smell or taste like
cheese it doesn't cheese dig a hole like
this holy correct it's really three ways
I'd eat one of these on a white bread
sandwich with Turkey all by itself on a
tortilla microwaved or folded in
quarters
and then eat it
mmm delicious cheese kinda I enjoyed
your survey and hopefully I'll see more
of it tomorrow